المترجم: imane ould bouya
المدقّق: muhammad Samir
تصفيق
حين أشاهد أمي
تهز رجليها
كمن يهدهد وليداً
وهي تغني " يا طيبين اللبن"
أعلم أنها قلقة جداً
على أحد اٍخوتي
لا تزالين
على عُتمة أيام الشعاع
يا أمان العالم
الطفل أنا
لازلت يا أمي
لازال يا أمي
إذا أفلت من ملفعك البني ضاع
عشت في زنديك أحلام صغار الطير
كان الحلم الأكبر لو باغتني البرد
ذراع
و إذا عدت من المأتم بالحلوى
عشت يا أمي تباريح الكتاكيت الجياع
أمُ
أمُ موجوع من الغربة قلبي
أو لازال لأوجاعي التي ضاق بها الكون
على برحة رجليك إتساع
إنني كلي حنين و ألتياع
طاوعتني في السُرى نحوك
أشواقي وأشعاري وأطياف حنيني
اٍنما الزورق يا أمي تأبى
لم يطاوعه الشراع
ساهر في السجن يا أمي
وعض القيد شيء غير عضات الفراق
ربما يصعد بي الشوق الي أقصى مقامات الشجى
اٍن بعض الشوق يأمي قراك
اٍنني بعضك
والغربة ضاقت بإشتياقي
كيف أمسي يا حنان الأرض كل الإشتياق
يا فؤاداً بإتساع الكون
ٍان البعد قد أشعلني كبريت أشواقاً على قلبك
ما أتعسني
أجني على الكون بهذا الٍاحتراق
هات كفيك
ٍاصهريني قبلة بينهما
مثلما سلت على خديك دمعاً
حمماً لاهبةً أغدو أنا حين أُراق
يا مزيجاً من عذابات الرفاق
لم تزل عيناك بحرين من اللوعة ما جاء
وأنا الممتد في خديك أنهار العراق
تصفيق
غارق يخنقني الاٍحساس بالذنب
فما أعنف هذا الاٍختناق
فصلتني إبرة الأيام جلباباً بحجم الشوق فيك
فتمزقت كثيراً كلما الجلباب ضاق
وتقلبت علي الوجد
وجيعي في النوى الشوق
اٍحترقنا من حرارات العناق
كلما حاولت أن أغفو علي وجنة أمي
ٍانفتل المصباح مني فإذا الشوق أفاق
ٍانني أدري
ٍاذا غبت ينام الكون في بيتي وأمي لم تنم
لايزال الليل يهتز علي الحجرالذي تأملني فيه
وما نام به غير الظُلَمْ
فاٍذا حنت يحن الباب والأعتاب والدولاب
وحتي بعض أشياء أبي المرحوم
تهتز علي وقعي الألم
وأنا في غربتي أدري بيها الآن تناغيني
وأدري من نشيجي المر مرفوع علي أي نغم
حينما تنشج أمي تسكن الأشياء في المنزل
حتي القلب
لو يقدر ماحرك في النبض
الذي يركض مقدار قدم
كل شيء ساكن في البيت
اٍلا صوت أمي
وخيالي عند رجليها
وشيء بين خديها إنسجم
ويصيخ الليل في الغرفة ما صعد
اٍلا صوت مزمار شجي اللحن من لحم ودم
يا
طيبين اللبن
بزين ماحلاكم
واٍذا غبت عن العين
حاشا القلب ينساكم
لو لو
وينام الليل مطوياً علي فيض المآقي
وأنا أغمضت عيني علي الدمع ولكن لم أنم.
السلام عليكم.
تصفيق